は）…ッハ　こんにちは
は）ドッキリのペテン師・・
は）あ、ペテン師は駄目か
は）「ドッキリの貴公子」はじめしゃちょーと
ま）まさき取締役です
は）ハイというわけで今ですね
は）僕ん家のいつも寝てる部屋があるんですけども
は）そこでトミックさんが…ｯハ　寝ております
どうぞ(紳士)
ｽﾞｶﾞｧｧｧｧｧ....
ﾌﾝｶﾞｧｧｧｧｧ
ｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬ...
ト）ﾝﾝﾝﾝﾝｩ↑ｳｳｳｩｩｩﾝ↓
……ﾃｨｰﾗﾝ
は)良い眠りでしたね。
ま)ねー…
は)いつもトミックさんが寝てるときにドッキリするんですけれど
は)僕結構「音が大きい系」とか「騒がしい系」をこう・・・やっちゃうんですよ
は）迷惑だなと思ってさぁ・・・
は）やっぱ、
は）トミックさんにはもっと・・・こう
は）安らぎというか、リラクゼーションというか
は）ほらためになるというか？
は）寝ながらでもこう・・・彼にはちょっと違うなんか
は）幸せな気持ちというか
は）プラスになることをしてあげたいんですよ、ほんと心からの優しさというか
は）というわけで今回はちょっとそういう
は）うるさくても嫌に起こすとか
は）トミックさんにそう・・・迷惑になることをせずに
は）もっと日頃の・・ってか久しぶりだったんだよね？
は）久しぶりにぼくトミックさんに会えたんですよ今回
は）なかなか忙しくてね
は）トミックさんをこの体の手入れとか
は）美容とかにあんまり気をつかえてないのかなと思ったので今回は
は）今回はですね
は）寝てるトミックさんの
は）鼻毛を
は）なるべく・・・（鼻毛カッター登場）
は）除去してあげたいと思います
は）いい企画ですね（棒）
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
は）感動ですよ（棒）
ｳﾞｩｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨﾝ↑
は）もうここに鼻毛入れれば切れるんで
ま）やだぁ///いれっへっははん///
は）一回だけ！！
は）ねぇ一回だけ///
ま）ほんとにやだぁ///
は）ほんとに先っぽだけでいいから（意味深）
ま）勘弁して///（満面の笑み）
は）先っぽだけでいいから（二回目）
ま）言い方やめろｗ
は）さきっ、先っぽだけでいいからｗ
は）この鼻毛カッターこれ結構いいやつで
は）鼻の穴の鼻毛がほぼなくなるという
は）便利な代物でございます。
は）日々忙しくて
は）なかなか鼻毛の手入れもできていないトミックさんであると思いますので
は）今回ね、その寝てる時間を使って
は）鼻毛の処理をしてあげたいと思います
ﾁｬﾗﾗｧ~ﾝ♪ﾗﾗｧﾝ♪（以下BGM）
（ｸﾞｯ）
（ｾｰﾌ）
（ﾆｺｯ☆）
ﾄﾞｩｸｼッ
ﾎﾟﾘﾎﾟﾘﾎﾟﾘ...
ﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛﾃﾛｫ↑
ｚｚｚ...ｯｯﾁｭｯ♡
ﾌﾞｩｨｨｨｨｨｨﾝ
ト）ﾊﾌﾝｯ（！？）
は）うわぁ！？ﾊｯﾊﾊｗｗｗｗｗちょｗ
ｳﾞｩｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨ↑ｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨﾝ↓
ﾌﾞｩｨｨｨｎｼﾞｮﾘｼﾞｮﾘｼﾞｮﾘｼﾞｮﾘ
ト）（ありがとう、はじめん...）
ｳﾞｩｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨｨﾝ
ト）（鼻毛がすっきり・・・）
ト）（ありがとはじめん・・・）
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓
ｚｚｚ...
ト）ﾝﾝ...ﾝｯﾝｯﾝｯﾝｯﾝ　ﾝｩ~~ﾝ//
ト）ﾝｩﾝﾝｯﾝｯ↑ｯﾝｩ~~ﾝ///